[Music]
be yourself
everyone else is already taken
we live in an age when unnecessary
things are our only necessities
always forgive your enemies
nothing annoys them so much
[Music]
we are all in the gutter but some of us
are looking at the stars
most people are other people their
thoughts are someone else's opinions
their lives a mimicry
their passions a quotation
women are meant to be loved not to be
understood
every saint has a past and every sinner
has a future
experience is one thing you can't get
for nothing
experience is merely the name men gave
to their mistakes
nowadays people know the price of
everything and the value of nothing
when one is in love one always begins by
deceiving oneself and one always ends by
deceiving others
that is what the world calls a
romance anybody can sympathize with the
sufferings of a friend
but it requires a very fine nature to
sympathize with a friend's success
a man's face is his autobiography
a woman's face is her work of fiction
i like men who have a future and women
who have a past
i choose my friends for their good looks
my acquaintances for their good
characters
and my enemies for their good intellects
[Music]
ridicule is the tribute paid to the
genius by the mediocrities
[Music]
men marry because they are tired
women because they are curious
both are disappointed
[Music]
between men and women there is no
friendship possible
there is passion
enmity
love
but no friendship
man is least himself when he talks in
his own person
give him a mask and he will tell you the
truth
when i was young i thought that money
was the most important thing in life
now that i'm old i know that it is
men always want to be a woman's first
love
women like to be a man's last romance
all women become like their mothers
that is their tragedy
no man does
that's his
the old believe everything the middle
aged suspect nothing
the young know everything
one should never trust a woman who tells
one her real age
a woman who would tell one that would
tell one
anything
the world is divided into two classes
those who believe the incredible
and those who do the
improbable ordinary riches can be stolen
real riches cannot
in your soul are infinitely precious
things that cannot be taken from you
you